okay hello and welcome everyone to heidi
daus's june meetup for those of you who
don't know
hi data is an educational program of a
nonprofit organization called num focus
the global high data network promotes
discussion of best practices new
approaches and emerging technologies for
data management processing analytics and
visualization we are a community of
users and developers of open source data
analyst analysis tools and this meetup
is a forum for us to share ideas and
learn from each other we also approach
data science using many languages
including but not limited to Python
Julia and arm my name is Anita and I'm
one of the co-organizers of high data
Boston I'm excited to have Robert ness
of us here today to talk about causal
modeling in machine learning but before
that I want to touch on a few items
first
feel free to introduce introduce
yourself in the chat and in slack
there's now an introduction channel and
slack as we continue to hold virtual
events we want to continue building our
community of course if you have
questions during the presentation send
them in the Q&A at the end of the
presentation you can start having some
real-time conversations and q and A's so
please turn off your microphone when
you're not speaking at that time there
we go so you can find us here on social
media feel free to tweet about today's
talk using hashtag PI data boss if you
have enjoyed our slack community yet
please do so this information is also on
our meter page as of all meetings we
want to reiterate that PI data is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
event experience for everyone please
behave professionally as we do not
tolerate harassment in any form you can
do the longer version of our code of
conduct at this website feel free to
reach out to any of the organizers if
you have any concerns so thank you for
helping us to make this a welcoming
friendly community for all lastly these
meetings are only made possible with the
help of volunteers you can do anything
from organizing an event by recruiting
speakers or
creating partnerships we're back to
meeting in person you might also help
secure venues and food you can also
volunteer to present and speak at one of
our meetings you don't have to have a
full talk ready either as the organizing
team can help you through it
in fact Robert filled out a Google form
on our meetup page saying that he was
open to speaking so I reached out and we
made this happen and with that I'll turn
it over to Robert to start presenting
hey can you hear me okay well hello
everybody thanks for joining I'm just
going to share my screen oh good and I
can see the chat so when I have my so I
need up I'll ask you to kind of help me
navigate a little bit when I'm gonna use
my keynote to present and I won't be
able to see the or you or anything
happening in the chat so I was gonna I'm
just gonna go and then it's something if
you need me to stop installing good hope
says that you have disabled screen
sharing let's try now yep already okay
so I try it this way
[Music]
can you see are you seeing like the
presenter view or the hold regular
presents bait you know the view for
everybody
I can't tell is it looking okay alright
alright okay well okay really happy to
be here at PI data bustin this is a
60-minute blitz on causal machine
learning it's based on the topic topics
of a course a workshop that I run on
this topic at DPA I enrollment for that
workshop is open now if you're
interested in rolling but it's really I
want to keep it really high-level and
kind of give you an impression of what
causal modeling is how it what its role
is in machine learning and you know how
we program it using Python and in
particularly a Python library that I'm
quite fun they've caught pyro so first
off of me a little bit about Who I am
machine learning research engineer I
focus on causal modeling and
probabilistic programming shops would
say worth a lot on natural language
processing work mostly in Python I write
and teach at dpi I did a PhD at Purdue
and instead of statistics focus there
was on causal inference I published in
places like drips and I'm married to a
really smart computer scientist I'm
fluent in Mandarin I I'm a published
poet under a pseudonym Tom never tell
you and I love functional programming in
particular that's my that's if I if I
could actually do that ring if there
were a lot of if there were more machine
learning and data science languages that
we're using that were more functional
I'd be a happier person
so to start so causality causal
inference if you're coming from
statistics or you're coming from say
public health or epidemiology or
economics you might have
some of this year in your studies and
some of your training but it's actually
quite new to the machine learning
community but we've had a better
articulation of the causal problems that
we need to solve in recent years so
recently judea pearl who was a very
pioneering generative modeling
probabilistic graphical models as well
as causal inference he published a book
public a popular science book I really
recommend it called the book of why and
he has a he talked mostly about the
social science type of applications of
causal inference but then towards the
end he starts talking about artificial
intelligence and you know has this
interesting story where he says like if
they bought were vacuuming my house
while I was asleep
and I told it you shouldn't have done
that now it's woken me up I wanted to
understand that it was the vacuuming
that was at fault I don't want it to
think that it should never back you
McGann because it's gonna make me
unhappy you should understand that they
should I understand I should have a
causal model of the world they should
understand intent it should understand
enough causal abstraction to know that
I'm upset now because you woke me up not
because you were vacuum
similarly Gary Marcus renowned
computational psychologist has came up
with a sorry he has a book called
rebooting AI waiting and he quotes we
need we need to start we need to stop
building systems that merely get better
at detecting statistical patterns and
datasets often using an approach known
as deep learning and start building
computer systems that from the moment of
their assembly innately grass three
basic concepts time space and causality
and the dirt the deep learning people
are also realizing that this is a place
that where we need to be solving
problems and that the problems are
causal in nature so this is Joshua Ben
Gao who was one of the founders of
modern deep learning and
he is this him in the talk saying once a
machine can understand it causal
structure of the world and produce plans
to take advantage of the fact that they
are not passive in the environment but
are active and can acquire knowledge
then we get to a better standard of
application so so that means that
they're understanding that for example
doing something will lead to an effect
and so if the agent is active and can do
that thing then it can choose to do
things that would give it more optimal
outcomes and so but in order to make
that kinds of talk that kind of choice
and needs to understand I have some
model of cause and effect so now most of
the machine learning conferences we see
workshops publications and tutorials on
causal modeling causal inference and we
also are realizing that to talk
effectively about the algorithmic bias
and AI fairness issue we need to have
some causal abstractions that allow us
to understand what's going on so that
image on the left there is a is taken
from the ProPublica article that
analyzed the compass algorithm that
predicted Lisa's recidivism recidivism
is discard describes a phenomenon of
describing whether or not somebody who
is released from prison goes on to
commit another crime
somebody somebody deployed it algorithm
n it was being used in a in a court
system to predict based on various
features whether or not an individual
who was up for release for early release
from prison would go on to would go on
to commit another crime and that was
being used by judges to to assess
whether or not to grant that person
release and it turned out that if based
on this analysis that if you if you kind
of control if you found people that were
that were alike in every aspect except
for race then
or every aspect that was under their
control except for race
you would see higher predicted risk of
of committing and knew that committing
on the crime for black people than white
people and in fact there were some cases
such as these two individuals where it
was quite egregious where the Perth
where the crime of the person of this
black woman was was a first offender and
it was a kind of a minor crime other
this man here was a repeat offender you
need a kind of causal semantics to make
that that kind of analysis repeatable
and easy to use so this this directed
graph here is a dag directed acyclic
graph it's a type of so we use this a
lot as a way of encoding our causal
assumptions about a system this this
type of framework can be used to analyze
whether or not an algorithm or whether
or not a system is for example actively
discriminating against a group of people
or maybe rather just reflecting lack of
representation by that group of people
in the pipeline that came into that
system in in which case it would not be
that system's fault when it says that
suggests that you need to change that
system it's a problem that came before
the system happened and so those are the
types of we need these types of
abstractions to understand this debate
so I'm going to talk about what a causal
model is and what exactly can do that
deep learning can't do I'm using deep
learning here not because it's different
from a causal model we can build causal
models of deep learning but just because
deep learning is what we considered to
be desserts that the state of the art in
machine learning I'll talk about what
the big tech companies are actually
doing with causality we we assume that
they're doing stuff with machine we know
what we're doing they're doing stuff
with machine learning so who should be
asking alright what are they doing with
causal inference and then maybe how this
causality and machine learning tie
together inside these organizations well
I'll answer the question
of how you can learn how to get involved
in causal modeling based on your
existing python-based skillset ideally
if you know some a little bit of machine
learning that would help a lot but and
but I'll introduce you introduce to you
some libraries to get started and then
I'll talk very briefly about the
workshop and then open it up for
questions so what can what is a causal
model and what can it do that deep
learning can't do so to understand
causal modeling we need to understand
the query and by query I mean it clearly
is something that we asked of the model
it could be just a prediction it could
be to infer that the value of some
parameter like in linear regression but
when we think about things in causal
terms we realize that there's different
levels of query so the basic level which
I call an association query this is
something that if you're done anything
with with machine learning or statistics
this is what you're used to this is
given some value of x predicted wires
all right so given the feature predict a
label given some covariance or some
predictors predict the regressor or the
outcome variable alright so in plain
words this would say something like you
know given someone on an exercise regime
what BMI are they likely to have so if
they go to the during giving somebody
takes CrossFitters and goes Orangetheory
what what is the probable range of BMI
that are likely to have let's predict
that right so deep learning is very
powerful for this type of question
because if you give it enough data it no
matter how how many features you have in
X how many how many how many how
multi-dimensional why is it can find
some nonlinear high dimensional
association between x and y i can find
some really high dimensional squiggly
line that's going to that's going to
represent the curve on the XY
relationship and fit that curve very
well now
the next level is intervention so
intervention means you actually go and
force a variable to take a certain value
and when you forcibly take a certain
value is no longer a random variable
that's kind of moving in response to
other random variables in the system
you've now artificially you've already
officially broken that randomness and
just fixed it but as an external force
on that system and so here we're saying
like I suppose that we kidnap somebody
and force them to exercise how would
that's what would be what would the
effect of that be on their on their BMI
right this is exactly what we do in a
clinical trial for example what we're
testing whether or not a drug has an
effect on a disease or if we're running
an a/b test where we're we're that
randomization that we do in an a/b test
is a type of intervention and we're and
we're fixing the value instead of
letting it be determined by nature and
so but what this does is by artificially
sticking your hand in there and fixing a
variable you're you're disrupting and
data generating process which means that
you're disrupting the process that
generated the training data which means
that that some if you just fit a model
on the training data unless it has
unless it's a causal model you're not
you know what the once you've done the
intervention you now you have now
created a created data you've created a
situation that has has deviated from the
situation that you had during when when
the training data was collected and so
in order to make that work in order to
have prediction under intervention we
made an explicit modeling of
cause-and-effect relationships and
finally we have this idea of a
counterfactual so this so the query here
is given X given a value for for X are
given a value for y what would Y have
been had X been different so this is
very much like an intervention another
way of saying this is that we we have an
intervention where we forced X to be a
we force we forced X to have some value
predict Y but we aught that that
prediction is conditioned on some
already observed
value of x and y that were different
from what were what the intervention and
what at what the internet intervention
was so we're we're and so this is
something that humans do a lot when a
reasoning so if i say given my current
BMI what would might be a BMI had been
had I been forced to do that exercise
regime right so it's now June had I
signed up for the gym back in January
how much you know what would my weight
be when I make that kind of when I make
that kind of inference that kind of
prediction I'm using information from
what my weight is now I'm comparing
myself in this world to to myself in a
in a parallel universe and this is very
difficult for machine learning
algorithms to do because they learn on
data they don't learn on could have been
data they learn on actual data but we do
this all the time as humans we say you
know had things have you know here's my
here's some outcome that I've
experienced I'm you know I'm I'm working
at a company and I'm very happy had I
chosen that other job offer I would be
less happy or I would be more happy and
that's not that's not based on actually
having had that experience is based on a
causal model in your head of how things
would have unfolded had you taken that
opportunity at other opportunity and so
this requires not only an explicit
modeling of cause-and-effect
relationships but a way to use the data
that has observed to predict the data
that could have been observed so we
often use the world twin worlds here we
have observed world we had a
counterfactual world and we need to make
our inferences take into account
evidence in the observed world and make
and make that make inferences me in the
counterfactual world so let's do some
examples using say a computer vision so
we're going to suppose that we have a
generative model of computer vision and
it has it follows this kind of structure
and so there's so at the the basic level
we have
we have pixels this is the image that we
we see and that there are three causal
factors here so let's just we've curated
this data set selectors there's there's
images of people training there's images
of people bloodied and there's images of
people posing for you know looking cool
because they're boxing right everything
and everything I forgot to mention
everything here these are all boxers
right and so we have training bot boxers
training we have blood need boxers and
we have posing boxers to jet we have two
genders
well these images we have two genders
male and female and we have the handful
of ethnicities in these images in these
examples we have black white and Asian
right and that bi-directional so those
those direct directed edges here they
they imply causality so that type causes
what you see in the pixels gender causes
what you see in the pixels etc we also
have and that's by directed edge there I
won't get into that but it's something
called this type of graph with a bi
directed edge it's called an ancestral
graph but what it means is that there's
there's some relationship some unmodeled
relationship between gender and
ethnicity so for example that we might
that maybe some ethnic groups will have
more representation from women than
others for example there might be you
know muy Thai Muay Thai fighters might
have more Asian women involved so so in
this first case an association suppose
that we randomly generates a bunch of
pictures from this model because of just
the way that's that the probability
distributions work in real life we're
gonna see that these samples will be
heavily skewed towards black and white
males although we'll see a variety of
types of images so training bloody
imposing right now for the intervention
what we're going to do is go into our
model and say fix gender to female and
then generate again and what would
happen here is and
seem to generate a female we might see
some more variety in ethnicity so that
implies that ethnicity kind of flows
causally from from gender or we might
not see if we did not see variety there
we might conclude that that gender is
determined do we have the gender makeup
of boxers tends to come from a data
generating process that has that has
ethnicity as a higher cause there but
here again I'm sober now we're looking
we fix we fix gender and we're seeing
we're seeing only we're saying we're
seeing only female boxers and but we see
the same distribution of type training
bloodied imposing finally we can look at
the counterfactual example which in this
case we've now generated an image or we
have an image and say this image of this
woman on the left and now we ask
ourselves like what would this and her
ethnicity is white and so we say what
would happen if we were to refix her
ethnicity to asian so this is again this
is we're thinking about a parallel
universe what kind of thinking about
what would this person look like in a in
some kind of bizarro universe where
she's not white but she's aging we can
you can get into how meaningful that is
of an intervention and that is it that
is the conversation we have in causal
inference all the time but what would
happen here is that nothing else about
the pixels should change like this
everything else that generated this
initial this initial image should be
fixed while only the elements core it
only be the patterns in the pixels
corresponding to ethnicity should we are
permitted to change here and so so there
and here you could so he fix it to Asian
ethnicity and then sample you could you
get some variance here of the same woman
but with with more Asian features and so
now we know that generative deep
learning can do this people do this with
Gans for example and so what makes
causal modeling difference in though in
those Gant examples in those
so again means janitor that network
those are these these these deep
generative machine learning techniques
that can generate hyper realistic images
and so the interventions and
counterfactual is in that setting you
can do that if you have specially
curated data sets and and special
training procedures and what you're
doing there's is effectively providing
the ability to do interpolation between
different sets of images so this
essentially what these fakes are doing
however for that to work you'd have to
plan in advance what it is you want to
do you want to plan your use cases in
advance and and spend a great deal of
effort training for for all those great
deal of effort and data training for
those specific use cases a truly causal
model can handle any causal query you
throw on it not just ones that you've
kind of planned in advance
it can also it should also take less
data to Train because there's more that
causal structures is built into tomorrow
it should be less glitchy and the
component should be transferable across
domains and that turns out to be really
important in fact if a causal
relationship in nature is invariant it
doesn't matter you know like the
relationship between altitude and
temperature is the same as it is in the
Himalayas as it is on the coastline we
and so because it's based on physics
right select type of invariance we
expect to we expect to see when we're
doing causal modeling and that should
help us with the transfer problem in
machine learning so talking a little bit
more about inventor interventions let's
understand why they're important and and
actually pretty ubiquitous in machine
learning and probably the biggest use
case for incorporating causal modeling
and machine learning when we deploy
machine learning systems in production
the reason we do it is not it's not just
a have fun or to do cool models or it's
it's because we want to make decisions
decision-making under uncertainty and so
when you make a decision you're making
an intervention possibly in the process
that generated their original data that
trait that generated the data that you
are using to train your algorithm and
possibly not so let's take an example so
here in this training block one what I'm
doing is I'm collecting the barometer
the readings of a barometer in the
morning so some kind of prediction or
some kind of more weather readings so
humidity just whatever I can say about
the weather from sensors in the morning
when I wake up and then I record what
the weather actually did that day a
little bit later right and so what I
want to do is be able to train a
predictive model that says like alright
given this this and you know these
environmental readings that I take in
the morning predict whether or not it's
going to be sunny today or it's going to
rain today now why do I want to make
that prediction because I want to make a
decision and that decision is whether or
not to take an umbrella with me when I
go to work
follow okay so we collect some data and
so we we run something we run training
on it and then we deploy that an app
that application to production and it's
and we start predicting some outcomes so
this first day it told me don't take an
umbrella and I didn't take an umbrella
so that's a check mark beans and I'm and
I'm happy the second day told me told me
it was gonna rain and so I brought an
umbrella and it was right third day it
was wrong told me arranged and told me
not to bring an umbrella and so you know
there was an error there and so we have
some acquiescent errors we has met we
have an error rate etc so we then there
fourth day we're right fourth they were
wrong fourth day it's sunny mother and I
brought an umbrella now I'll take that
data and I'll feed it back into the
training algorithm so now I have block 1
and block 2 as as my training data and
so I'm getting more data as I go and and
yet hopefully the algorithm get smarter
and smarter
what's important about this is that the
weather doesn't really care about
whether or not I bring an umbrella if I
bring an umbrella it doesn't affect the
weather but there are many cases where
this type of prediction predictive
algorithm does leads to decisions that
affect the data that's used to train
that algorithm an example a very common
example would be in in advertising so in
this case I'm looking at a economic
prediction an outcome an outcome
forecast and I decide whether or not
based on that forecast to to increase or
decrease my advertising spend so I take
that data and I and I feed it to their
train ab training algorithm and then and
then based on that first initial pass I
am deciding whether or not to purchase
the net so you know so in the first case
I don't purchase an ad and revenue
one-up so great and second in the second
case or set ourselves what happen the
second case sales is going down it
predicted that sales is going down so I
do purchase an ad and that's the right
choice third case predict the sales are
going down I don't which is mad let's
say that's wrong choice etc but what
happens here is that every time I when I
make it when I when I run an ad or I
don't matter that it affects the iraq
the the sales order revenue that come in
at the next time point right so I am
there's the Detroit my algorithm is
telling me to do things I have to make I
to purchase an ad or not purchase to
that but that decision affects the data
that I'm collecting in blot two as I'm
as I'm acting on the prediction so data
comes in I get a I get a prediction I
make a decision that affects the next
data point that comes in and so now the
behavior of my algorithm is now feeding
back into the data
I then treaty to retrain the data on
this new block on block 2 as I'm blood
to and and I get this kind of feedback
effect where I am now
the behavior of my algorithm is now part
of the training that the process of
generates a training data and that and
that is being used to to retrain the
algorithm and then that repeats over and
over again we get like a negative
feedback effects this kind of thing
happens in a great example of how this
can be a problem is in for credit-card
fraud detection so if if for example you
train an algorithm that can predict
fraud and then your algorithm stop
starts blocking fraud then your actual
the data that you collect are just it's
just the kinds of you get you get a
whole bunch of cases of legitimate
transactions and a few cases of fraud
transactions but these are a special
kind of fraud that were smart enough to
beat your algorithm so now you're
retraining algorithm on those on those
cases and then you're gonna start
biasing your algorithm to more and more
kind of outlier cases of fraud and that
can lead to problems and then finally we
can we're using counterfactual modeling
for making agents interest modeling
agents that are that are that are making
decisions under uncertainty so this is
bandits
this is Markov decision processes
reinforcement learning what you see up
here if you're not familiar is the
bellman equation which is the equation
and they of course of learning in them I
reloaded here to use a kind of causal
modeling syntax namely that that do
notation that you see in there but well
the reason we want to do this is we want
our we want agents to reason like we do
we want our agents to reason
counterfactually so if for example we
can look at us as the modeler can look
at some law of data and say alright so
based on these logs have we given this
agent a different policy of
decision-making how much better would it
have been
had it done you know on these instances
that we've already recorded that's a lot
cheaper just asking that question and
getting a good answer
it's a lot cheaper than actually running
say an a/b test between two policies
because if you're running the policy
you're actually having to expend
resources and time and perhaps lot of
profit internet by cheque trying things
out on actual users as opposed to things
that have already happened in you have a
nice yeah you have a lot of history of
that happening you can also do this in
an online setting you can have the
agents kind of update its policy as is
making decisions and say like all right
look he's looking back at its own
history you can say all right I'm
looking back at what I did you know
maybe five hands ago in this game of
poker
I did what I made the decision that I
thought was best at the time and this is
where I am now this is the outcome I'm
seeing now I think I would have gotten
more more reward more more utility had I
done a different action five five hands
ago and so based on that conclusion I'm
going to update my policies so that's
when I hit similar circumstances I'll
make a better decision so next question
is what are the big tech companies doing
with causality how does it tie into what
they're doing with machine learning so
we expect Google and Facebook to be
doing cutting-edge of machine learning
are they cutting edge of causal
inference the answer is yes they are and
but the strange thing is is that within
for now within these within these teams
at these companies there's actually very
little interaction between teams that
are working on machine learning and
teams that are working on causal
inference I personally think that's a
problem I think it's an opportunity as
well so to understand exactly how this
works like Alan X I want I need to
explain a concept to you first this idea
called a causal reasoning engine once we
know what once we know what that is
understand how it's actually deployed in
an industry so we start with the causal
model when it has some causal assumption
so this causes that fat causes that
coughs this and some parameters or
weights where we want to call them that
that kind of quantify those
relationships then once we have this
model and we once you actually do some
inferences we have some observations
some evidence some things that we've
observed we have a question that we want
to ask a query the first thing we need
to do is check whether or not this this
question can be asked given this data
that's called identify that's got an
identifiability check turns out that in
causal inference what a big question you
have is like this I have a headless
causal question can I even answer it
given my data and it's kind of a if
you're coming from a machine learning
engineering background that can
sometimes be a hard thing that wrap your
head around is if you're used to being
able to just kind of power through
things with more data and then we need
we have an S demand which is kind of
like a recipe for calculating the answer
to the query and then we have the
estimator which is just statistics now
that we we know how to estimate the
query
what's our estimation procedure going to
be so we have these causal assumptions
and the question now becomes how do we
represent them common way of doing that
is with directed acyclic graphs or DAGs
so in a very nice easy straightforward
way of representing your cause or
assumptions so the nodes represent
components or variables in a causal
system and the edge corresponds to a
causal relationship so here you know
this very canonical example you'll see
if you look it up on Wikipedia that the
wetness of the grass is caused by birth
both the sprinkler being on or off or
the rate or whether or not it's raining
so let's pretend we're Netflix and ask
ourselves some questions about our data
Netflix recently launched a so called
space force and it's a show that's
produced by Netflix now yeah so she's
your question time bread and butter
machine learning or Ben better
statistics what is the probability
someone who saw the trailer will go on
to watch the show right so we can kind
of just query the database get some
counts of people who you know find
people watch a trailer and then just
count how many people actually went on
the watch the show
use that as like an estimate for the
probability
that's its kind of stats 101
intervention question what's the
probability that somebody will watch
this show if we show the trailer to them
so that's a little bit different from
the first one in the first case we're
actively we're actually actively
choosing to show someone a trailer with
the goal of making them watch it as
opposed to say for example them
stumbling upon the trailer maybe by
accidents if you know honestly if
they're in Netflix there's you know and
the way the Netflix works is that
there's no nothing happens in your right
eye right now random leaders everything
that wears nuclear driven but you might
have seen the trailer for example on
YouTube and then decided to to go and
see see that show or not see the show
for that reason but even in a case where
Netflix is telling you is doing an a/b
test or as art is determining who to
show the trailer to algorithmically
which is you know so it's doing an
intervention there still might be some
other issues some things that happen in
between Washington trailer and actually
watching the show right and so for
example so some kind of assignment
mechanism has me watched a trailer but
then some things happen I did make a
decision about whether or not to read a
review article that decision is impacted
by whether or not I saw advertisers for
for space for us on Facebook or Twitter
whether or not I saw advertisers for
space porcelains on Twitter or Facebook
determines whether or not I my friend
recommends it because your social
network correct these are social
networks right so I and then they're my
friends recommendation also impacts
whether or not I go onto internet review
article so and reading the review
article and my friends recommendations
and and whatever other exposure I saw in
in in Twitter all goes on to impact
whether or not I see the show along with
whether or not I saw the trailer and so
but what you're really interested in is
a second type of question is that blue
to disclose
in there which is kind of muddled
together with all with all that pinks
the so statistical associations so like
you wanna the whole goal of causal
inference here which would be more
specifically we call this causal effect
inference is to kind of distill that
blew from that pink we want to know that
direct relationship and and and and
isolate that from other confounding
factors is confounding is a term that we
want to we want to call these other
factors here and so we have in so causal
inference and industry tends to be some
experimenting some experimentation and
physical techniques that make that blue
sophistical effect identifiable and and
in a way that minimizes bias and
variance so these tend to be
statisticians or people with say
backgrounds in the epidemiology or
economics who have where there's a whole
kind of research methodology methodology
devoted to this question we can also ask
the kind of factual questions so this
show was launched in May and Robert
that's me
watched it if they launched it in June
or I'm sorry if we watched it in June
when we as Netflix would we still have
what Roberts still have watched it so
you know the timing of launching these
shows is very important in that flick so
they want to know if I did watch it at
some given point can that tell them
whether or not I still would have
watched it at another time point or we
might ask the question that you know
right Robert has watch the show would he
have watched what would he have watched
otherwise so if we did not if we do not
recommend spaceforce to him well else
what would what would he have watched
instead would he have watched other
Netflix produced content that's less
ideal right because then space force is
merely cannibalizing off of other it's
kind of license users off of other
Netflix Netflix produced content if it's
taking me away from Netflix licensed
Khan
and that's less profitable to now
Netflix that's that's better
right and it's taking me away from a
competitor like Amazon or Disney or HBO
that's best right so who now we're going
way beyond just Lake Erie how many
people like to show - how many people
have much to show who would have
otherwise to watched something we don't
want them to watch so this is an example
of causal inference close to Facebook
probably bit dated at this point but and
you know so in Facebook and Twitter and
many of these companies it's often
focused on marketing and advertising
asking you know so for example in
marketing is a problem called
attribution that's fundamentally a
causal inference problem also being used
for features like what's you know if I
make this change to a feed what will be
the effect of the user's consumption of
content on the site and you need to kind
of compare that to what the effect would
have been otherwise if you had not
introduced a feature or to a baseline
change for example similarly in this
posting we're looking for people who can
do experiments on or do causal reasoning
on algorithm so this is the sale this is
to say like can we run till we use kind
of causal inference combine the
statistical experimentation to
understand sets of hyper parameters for
an algorithm that would optimize its
performance so so now I want to answer
the question how this how you can learn
causal modeling based on your existing
machine learning and data science skill
set so you know I have a bunch of texts
appear on causal inference if you were
if you really wanted to kind of
traditional way of learning causal
inferences the grab a book like like
this or something like that and just
kind of drill away at it and it's just
it's it's like you know basically
getting another getting getting master's
degree in something that's unrelated to
some of this
you've probably already been working on
so the real question is like how can we
get people to learn this stuff as a as a
direct extension of their existing skill
set so to talk about that I want to talk
first a little bit more about these
causal tags within within the causal
inference community reliance on a dag
it's a bit of a topic of debate
everybody tends to agree that they're
great for looking at right the great for
kind of saying like I believe it just
causes this and discusses that they're
great for for visual representations of
your assumptions that you can
communicate to other people you can use
to communicate with other people
some people prefer would like to use
them directly in the causal reasoning
engine like we just did so in other
words you're taking your your causal
assumptions and coding them in a dag and
then you're and then the algorithms that
you use during inference are based on
that bag lots of people don't like that
particularly people from social science
background because the fundamental
question is what if your causal dag is
wrong and that really matters in social
science or public health because a wrong
Marla leads the bad policy but in
machine learning we love using wrong
models we do it all the time we do and
we just well use a wrong models so long
as it's useful right so this happens a
lot and say latent variable models or in
other words directed graphical models
like mixture models matrix actor ization
hidden Markov models you know these
things have a directed acyclic graph
representation often in a form of plate
models so we can capture that
multidimensionality and they're
implicitly causal right so like in ISM
in this mixture model that we're saying
the Davis observed XM XM n variable is
that the observed data comes from this
switch right that's this this there's
some kind of mechanism this kind of
switched variable z2 determines which mu
which Gaussian mean or mixture mixture
distribution mean that's the that the
that
comes from so there's so zis is it's
causing X in a certain way Wow alpha
theta nu here kind of waits for that
causal relationship and we usually don't
treat this as a true causal model my
argument is that we could and we should
so I think there's a new opportunity for
if iterative model building so one day
so the traditional way of model building
and machine learning and data science is
one that criticizes a model based on
evidence so this is the model builds
sorry that the builds in the basic all
the build computes critique repeat
flowcharts by david by where you first
build a model or you go so this is where
you put in all the structure and and you
kind of assume some kind of parametric
form you train it on data and then you
criticize the model so criticizing care
means I do a goodness I use goodness of
fit or I use I look at performance on
some kind of prediction task or I I do
posterior predictive checker or
or some kind of predictive checker I
look at information criterion whatever
it is all of these things are just based
on on evidence right like how well does
my model explain the data that I'm
seeing right
and so that's so it's kind of an
evidence-based approach to building a
model we just iterate it trying to get
models that that are better better and
better and better fits for the evidence
i'm argue if we have a cop we took a
causal modeling approach because the
ability to criticize the model using
falsifiability so falsifiability is this
idea from from science from Karl Popper
here so you can't prove a hypothesis I
know in other words a model is true or
even have evidence that it is true by
induction but you can refute it if it is
false so this is so it put in common
terms that like we if I
if I advise and I observed some evidence
that come up with a model that explains
it
I can't prove that model is true but I
can falsify that model because if for
example I if if the assumptions of the
model are not don't hold up against
reality then my model simply can't can't
can't be true and and I can and so I
should I can falsify that model and then
maybe I could think about models that
are harder to falsify so causal models
this really eat there they are really
easy to falsify they have the set of
assumptions that you build into a causal
model or are depending on the data you
have you can you can you can test those
assumptions and if there's a violation
if empirical evidence violates those
assumptions you have falsified your
model it's this particularly when it
comes to interventions if I predict
that's you know I predict that
increasing advertising will have a
certain increase in sales and then sales
goes down i falsified my model and so we
can do the intervention in reality what
if I predicted advertising will increase
sales and then I do be advertisement and
sales goes down that I falsified my
model so if we do the intervention
reality and the outcome does not match
the prediction then the model is
falsified and we can so if we can
formalize our models as causal models we
can we can pick up that iterative model
building approach and what we do is
instead of trying to find models that
fit the data really well we try to we
try to we try to eliminate models that
are falsified by the data and once we've
once we've eliminated all the things
that we can we can falsify then we we
kind of switched to an evidence evidence
based iteration to try it optimize it so
this is a this is a technique that's
that made George Soros rich so straw
Soros the as a billionaire trader
currency trader he was Karl Popper
student I think it London School of
Economics and you know he took poppers
theory of you know ideas about
falsifiability and
into a trading strategy where basically
you know you go on you go on Bloomberg
you go on CNBC and you see people
telling you you know they're models of
how economics works and how finance
works and they stick by their models and
they're the ones who believe in this
monetary theory or they believe in that
and that kind of thing George Lewis
comes up with the model he tries very
hard to prove that model was wrong and
the second he sees evidence that it's
wrong he rejects it and updates it and
so he said oh I'm only rich because I I
know what I'm wrong
I basically survived by recognizing my
mistakes that's uh so you know when you
have skin in the game like that's tends
to kind of favor this this
falsifiability based approach it's very
easy in machine learning for us to move
from generative models to causal to
other models it really just takes well
it just really requires us to take that
structure of the model and and and and
use it as a way of encoding our causal
assumptions about the system so finally
I want to talk a little bit about the
best libraries to get started so in my
course I focus on two two packages one
called be and learn which is an R
although there is a package called PGM
PI and Python which it has it has a
completely different interface but they
there's basically 90% overlap in the
functionality well it's not true when it
comes to evaluating causal assumptions
there's ninety percent overlap and the
functionalities these two packages are
being learned is actually primarily
concerned with learning structures from
data in both causal and but but but
largely non-causal settings but so if
you go to I'll show you in the at the
end of this will show you some links
inside of my github repository where you
can see some tutorials on this thing the
pros of this ability of this process of
this modeling approaches that's I can
handle interaction predictions and it
can you can do causal effect estimation
you can infer values of latent barrier
again inference is relatively easy
because you're working with it with a
directed acyclic graph and so you can
rely purely on belief propagation and
other probabilistic graphical model
based inference algorithms and it's easy
to reason on a directed graph a directed
acyclic graph so both so again both of
these packages rely on directed acyclic
graphs and having the directed acyclic
graph it comes in handy when you're
trying to do inference algorithmically
and when you're trying to reason on the
system cannot handle counterfactual
specifically the general kinds of twin
world counterfactuals that I described
earlier they're not open world an open
world means that you that you know you
have to specify in advance the number of
variables in the system they can't the
number of variables in the system can't
be generated say for example through a
control flow so like if if this variable
is true then there's ten variables but
it's yeah there's ten variables that's
have this outcome but if this but if
that value is false then there's one bit
but has it outcome you can have having
some control flow allows you to be a lot
more flexible about the modeling can't
do that when you have a day and these
packages don't allow you to work with
arrays or tensors so you can't really
take advantage of some of the advanced
advances in deep learning we can go
beyond the dag with probabilistic
programming so if you're if you're I
assume that the PI data group have seen
some Python based probabilistic
programming languages before like PI mc3
or stand for example if you're familiar
will stand as a just an alone language
but integrates in Python and are
tensorflow probability and Edward are
other examples and Julie others for
Turing Omega actually the guy behind
Omega guy named Xena is a has a
a causal modeling version of it which i
think is really exciting although it's
it's doing a kind of research base now
so what the way to think about
probabilistic programming here is that
you know is that it's a way of kind of
making turing-complete causal models so
leaking bayesian networks are kind of
generative models based on a dag any any
any causal Bayesian network you can
represent in a probabilistic program so
the question becomes now that we relaxed
the assumption that you have to have a
dag what kind of what advantage do you
get from that added next expressiveness
and so you can actually use the
probabilistic programming to to model
very mech mechanism causal mechanism
very richly and then kind of analyze
that when analyzing the control flow of
a probabilistic programming and I mean
and and you can also use recursion for
example to have decision-making agents
reason about themselves as part of a
causal system right so instead of kind
of thinking of you have a standalone
causal model the causal system and you
have an agent that's reasoning about
that agent can now become part of the
system and make decisions within that
system and take into account its own
behavior and so you can do that with
kind of really recursion basically and
so one example the kind of causal query
you can answer here is counterfactual
crazy say for example there were 10
missiles fired and the radar detected
all of them but had there been more than
20 missiles we would have missed at
least one right so you have a little bit
we have a kind of open-ended number of
missiles and we we have an open number
of you know number of the number of
missiles you might have missed and we
want to kind of a set a probability on
this statement that requires causal
probabilistic programming so in a repo
that's some I use the pyro package and
the pyro package I it was a pie torch
based probabilistic programming
language it's also based there's also a
numpy rule which is based on numpy there
is there is this is the only
probabilistic programming language that
that I use that that's open-source I
there's one that I use with the AI team
I work with but that's proprietary that
has explicit causal abstractions built
into the programming language namely a
do operator if you know what that is
and so it's if you go it so you can you
can handle counterfactuals you can you
can it Frigg and then you can do the
other things that you can do with the
Bayes net and then of course you can
it's a it's based on PI torch so that's
multi multi dimensionality working
tensors and using that you can do with
deep learning and working with inference
frameworks such as stochastic Mary
variational inference that it allows you
to do all that to answer causal queries
which makes it very powerful it could
also handle these open world settings
look at this subscribed but they're hard
you know if you decide you get rid of a
dag things become a little bit become a
lot harder to reason about and harder to
do inference so one of the challenges of
probabilistic programming I'm hoping
we'll probably get better at this in the
future but it's really it's you'd like
to be able to kind of specify a model of
arbitrary complexity and then just have
inference work in real life you have to
kind of write your own inference
algorithm I think it can be pretty tough
especially if you're trying to raise and
cause of tariffs actually so talk a
little bit about the workshop IP it
covers all of these topics romans open
now if you're interested its ends in
four days but we touched on general
bottling causal inference causal agent
modeling kind of graphical modeling
theory basically everything you need to
know the web these two universes
together as causal inference universe
and degenerate machine learning universe
and you know you get to communicate with
get access to me and the other
instructors when you have questions and
you need to prop help with the homeworks
you learn how to how these causal
inference algorithms are applied in
top-tier technology organizations if
you're if you've worked in causal
efforts and you tried to learn causal
inference you see all the examples were
usually about drugs and healthcare and
stuff like that which which of course
very important applications but a lot of
the people in my audience are much more
interested in saying you know doing the
kind of things that we saw those job
descriptions for Netflix and Facebook
and of course we're using those those
probabilistic programming languages as
opposed Python libraries that as opposed
to using kind of black box packages for
for causal inference so we're building
the models ourselves I have a PI data
10% off core course code if you're
interested there's there's two prep type
pricing plans one for the full price and
one for monthly payments those are the
coupon codes and because this is
recorded in the go altom i'll put a
24-hour loop runs
Oh are there any questions I guess I'll
stop sharing actually let me actually
show you I think can you still see my
screen now I'm going to show you the
repo so the course you gotta pay for but
the where is you have multiple screens
and then you're trying to use everywhere
for I'm still sharing can you see my
screen Nina can you nod your head if you
can see my screen yeah thank you
okay that's wrong didn't we see yeah
sure just stop - okay
so this is the repo of course you gotta
pay for about everything to repo you can
just you know it's it's open there on
github under an MIT license so namely we
have some tutorials here that you can
run through so this is a reinforcement
learning example one with a variational
auto encoder I actually have it there's
a PR tool about foot true don't have a
whole bunch of updates here we actually
can see some of them past student
projects work and so you can see some of
the analyses that other people have done
here so this is an analysis where people
have tried to come up with a causal
model for predicting what kinds of how
what kind of house you should buy in
order to optimize we turn on Airbnb
rentals another one where some students
were used coming up with a
object-oriented programming approach to
causal modeling and and and the ORM
mapping to a database so that you could
have kind of a knowledge base of causal
relationships and then kind of
instantiate those into models would be
able to do interesting things this is
done by this Moneyball here was done by
some students who are interested in and
her and wanted to predict find causal
effects on certain finds the causal
relationship between certain factors and
the transfer price of ball players this
is using a a latent variable model
called it de a.d confounder model to try
to predict the out the box-office output
box-office revenue of a movie based on
deciding whether or not to cast an actor
so the the problem here is to say you
know certain we could see a correlation
between actors and and the revenue for
movies but some movies have actor have
actors and actresses in we wouldn't
expect them to actually have a causal
relationship with the box-office revenue
so one example might be the actress who
plays mrs. Moneypenny and James Bond
movies Bond movies technic grows really
high she tends to only be in those
movies so she's very hot correlated with
high grossing movies but we know that
there's some confounding there so the
James Bond miss of the movie is really
why that movie is making that much money
and why that movie has her cast for it
similarly there's that woman are correct
for everything excuse my mind who plays
Robin and How I Met Your Mother
she's in all of those Avengers movies
but we can you know so we might say like
well whatever movie she's in tends to
like break box office records but that
would be that's that's what machine
learning would tell us but that would be
a causal inference to tell it which
should tell us otherwise and so we
wouldn't be able to train models that
can make that kind of understanding
here's some some recent work on modeling
the the effect of interventions namely
stay at home policies in an epidemic
using compartmental models for
epidemiology and then we have some
reinforces learning examples as well
[Music]
for your presentation during and while
you were talking there are people who
asked some questions already in the Q&A
so we'll just go through those and then
we'll have a bag of cork talk with
attendees so Michael asked would you
recommend using causal modeling if you
only have observational data yes and so
it depends of course on the objective
but I would I would have I personally
prefer using causal modeling for any
modeling problem what that means is so
put it like this so if you've read a
book on say generative machine learning
so Riley recently has a book ano
generative deep learning or yeah
generative deep learning in it and the
whole first chapter is talking about
thinking about the data generating
process and and its relationship to the
underlying joint probability of
distribution of everything that's inside
your data and and you know and this is
that this is kind of the philosophy of
probabilistic programming as well
you want to be thinking about the
process that generates the data and if
you and if the fact is just because of
the way the human brain works
you really can't think of a generating
process without applying some kind of
causal theory to it right like for
example a topic model the topic cause
the appearance of words in the document
and so you should you know so if you
have this observational data I would
suggest Yeah right right outs a dag that
kind of represents that the
relationships between those variables
and any latent variables that are not
captured by that your data set that you
believe are nonetheless part of the data
generating process and need to be
modeled explicitly now once you have
that dag you can ask the question of
whether or not the if you--if you want
to ask something causally in your data
like for example this this variable
cause that variable
you can you can ask causal in the causal
inference will tell you
given this dag can I even answer that
question given data that I have and and
then if I can and I'll tell you some
formulas for for calculating that causal
effect for example The Adjustment
formula yeah next question is can you
recommend some resources or case studies
to read more about causal inference
attenuating data feedback effect and
maybe the relationship of that with
concept drift if any so for example when
you need tech concept drift you have to
retrain and update your model but it
might affect your model in the way that
you describe with the fraud model right
so don't know of any there's very little
literature out there for fusing causal
inference style reasoning into concrete
machine learning problems most people in
the machine learning community right now
are thinking about I have two things one
is like I had there's a relationship
between two variables and I want to just
figure out which way causality goes
number two is in latent variable models
like say variational auto-encoders
they're often interested in
disentangling factors inside the latent
variable which it was politically a
causal question like they want to figure
out what are the causes and can we
separate them out now but kind of
capturing things like concept drift you
know I think I think the so this is I
think the best place to go would be
aside from my stuff
this book doesn't talk this is Peter's
dancing and show coughs book they don't
talk about this issue directly but it's
the best book that I've seen the best
published book that I've seen in terms
of connecting causal modeling causal
inference to red and rudder problems in
machine learning I think that'd be good
graces not tickets if the credit fraud
problem is kind of closer to problem the
surety on most people in industry who
attacked that kind of problem use
something called propensity score
matching so if you start googling around
propensity score matching that might
come up with some techniques that could
solve your problem if it's if the two
problems are related so next question is
which companies are working on the
causal inference and learning that tag
so learning the dag so there is a
problem causal inference called causal
discovery we're trying to learn the tag
structure from data and so I've written
some papers on this and it's it's about
causal discovery is a popular method in
systems biology computational biology so
any kind of computational biology
company that is interested in
understanding the structure of
regulatory pathways and molecular
biology so this you know so this could
be synthetic biology companies like
ginkgo Bioworks this could be you know
Daphne Koller who wrote a whole book on
probabilistic graphical models and she's
now CEO of a vape I have a
machine-learning slash biology company
at things called in Citroen Citroen
Sitra or something I forget so so but in
the bio it is also one in Boston called
gns healthcare they they also do some
discovery I've talked to some people
at quantum black which is the data
science arm of McKinsey and turns out
the three are interested in doing causal
discovery learning bags from data and so
that would obviously be in business
applications that discuss surprised me
when I discovered that no people were
actually using these techniques in in
that domain but other than that I think
the most practical problems almost a
better way to go is to actually rather
than try to you know learn bags from
data which tends to be really hard when
there is missing when there's missing
variables which is almost always I think
it's I think it's it's good to try to
come up with your own that do some
experimental data analysis and
understand the structure of the data and
and then combine that with your own
domain knowledge to come up with
candidate bags and then try to falsify
those tags based on their data I think
you can combine that all those to find
out those discovery techniques but in my
experience particularly in kind of
machine learning examples it's better to
try to use your own kind of human you
know wetware to come up with tags as
opposed to rely on algorithms but you
can use algorithms and they support
Ronald asked is it possible to learn
causal relationships that we can't
explicitly define yet I do know that we
can learn dag structures that fit
training data but I was just curious if
there are any other methods that might
work better so there's a difference
between mechanism and causal
relationship so every causal
relationship has an underlying mechanism
but it might not necessary for us to
learn that mechanism and not and
oftentimes we can't learn to make
mechanism without you know scientific
experimentation so we can we can find
and operate on the just adjust the
knowledge of the causal relationship
itself and that might be enough example
it just happens
in biology right so like there are many
drugs that have been around for a long
time where people don't particularly
understand the mechanism of action right
I think aspirin is one of those examples
you know there are several others but
like you know this is something that
we've been taking people take this since
we understand as well understood it
there's lots of studies on it and yet if
you try and go in there and figure out
exactly causally how the the aspirin is
relieving the headache there's actually
not that much knowledge about what that
mechanism looks like but that's enough
for us to know that we still know that's
that taking an aspirin will cure a
headache and so there are errors
probably you know the pain on your
application it's a reason when you
really need counterfactual reasoning
often requires some specification of
mechanism but really if you're just
trying to understand say the causal
effect of this thing on that thing
especially in applications like and
advertising and a/b testing and
sequential decision making simply kind
of knowing that there's a relationship
between two things I think then there's
an answer the question let me know the
last question is Giuseppe likes books
and paper and is wondering if you can
suggest some good books or influential
papers just say I just have you like
books on books tanta oh oh just that'd
be like the books and paper I see yeah
so so papers say unearth my big mountain
of unread papers so just gonna me feel
bad but I will tell you
so for well well I'll show you the these
authors are not about to show you will
have good book so you know today at
Pearl though obviously is a very
important person in both genitive
machine learning and in causal inference
this is his is a text book on the
subject
this reads like an encyclopedia it's the
kind of thing that you buy and then kind
of consult it's not you know it's it's
hard to read cover to cover for that you
can read his popular science book as I
mentioned called the book of Y and but
as I mentioned Peter chancing a show
coughs book elements of causal inference
it's probably my favorite text book
there's a Riley has a book is probably
they'd at this point and this is written
by Samantha Kleinberg so this would be
more towards the the economics and
statistics kind of approach to causal
inference less about the less less
degenerative modeling approach that I've
described here but also a good read and
also for a more technical introduction
by Perl this book this primer by Perot
clamor and Jule causal inference in
statistics very thin this is you know
reading the book of Y and then reading
this and then kind of having causality
there when you want to kind of go into
the proofs and stuff like that that's a
that's a great way to go I think someone
snuck in one last question could you
discuss what the ideal prerequisites
would be for this course
and how to apply the discount for the
course so I could put those coupon codes
right there just well yeah so that goop
those coupon codes I gave out and I'm
sorry Meera's its first so you should
know what joint probability is and
conditional probability is what
expectation is expected value so ends
variants so really just kind of those
basic those basic elements of I guess
you would call that probability theory
so like yeah random variables joint
probability conditional probability
Bayes rule expectation variance and not
so much all the properties of
mathematical relationships rufino's
think she's gotta know they are and and
decided from that and then if you're
comfortable with if you're comfortable
with Python which I assume here you are
through on this call that would make
things a lot easier if you're working on
the homeworks and the capstone project
but yeah and that's about it everything
that we do kind of we'll just we'll
build on is basically core concepts of
of joint and conditional probability
distributions as for the coupon posed
when you go to take out page there
should be there should be a place to
apply the coupon codes reach out to me
on Roberts at all to steep AI if you
can't there's an issue and you can't get
it to work I can paste those codes again
in this chat miss them yeah I'm going to
a new participants in case there are
other questions that have come up that
people just want to ask real-time so
hopefully at this point people should
see that they have the ability to chat
Robert did put his coupon codes for his
course on the
chat as well anyone else have questions
going once
the message will recording of the
session below so we will make the
recording available at some point we
have to figure out how to get that to
everyone though so but we we will have
your slides to send out fairly soon
right yeah we did you make that
available to everyone both the slides
and the recording hey sounds like there
are no other questions this is the part
this is the part we usually like have
banter and then like eat pizza and stuff
like that and I don't have to do that
because of kool-aid so I wish were
resume equivalent to that well thank you
everyone for joining thank you Robert
for presenting and we hope to see you at
our next Heidi and I Boston event take
care thank you